ce qu'on voit c'est cdc l'effet de ce
qui a été nommé le néolibéralisme depuis
une trentaine d'années terre une
politique quand même d'exacerbation de
la concurrence entre les instances et
les individus d'une part d'autre part de
de maximisation de la spéculation des
flux que ce soit économique marchandises
tout ce que vous voulez et donc de et
donc leur réduction de ski jane les flux
c'est à dire les stocks qu'on voit là
c'est le double le solutionner site
écologique est une autre chose qui moi
même me gêne terriblement depuis le
début c'est un accent sur la
responsabilité individuelle et on voit
exactement la même chose que dans le
réchauffement climatique a des gens qui
arrêtent pas être vous dira si vous
triez vos déchets si vous triez votre
verre on va rentrer de réchauffement
climatique bah non c'est pas ça il ya
aussi des tout un tas d'industrie était
pas allé de deux d'entreprise de deux
très grosses en général etc qui donc
tout un système économique qui produit
le réchauffement climatique ici c'est
pareil on fait tout un tout un foin de
2000 rêveur bref parti en bretagne qui
sont complètement irresponsable ok mais
il est clair aussi que on a des d'écoles
la majorité des universités j'ai des
collègues qui jusqu'en novembre enseigné
à 60 dans les salles sans fenêtre et ben
c'est c'est des millions de gens qui
sont exposés et pas par le fait que
c'est des fêtards et qui vont faire la
fête par l'état français et la politique
en termes de l'éducation nationale
[Musique]